uh shimano mahmoud thank you so much for
being with us and good morning
to you um i wonder if we can just pick
up if we make so i think i know what
you're going to say about that liz trust
policy and which she's rode back on but
i wonder if we can pick up on how well
the labour party doing right now against
the conservative parties there is a lead
in the polls the latest polls have come
in but only a one percent lead why is it
still so tight
oh well look i mean uh the polls of the
last few months have been showing the
labor party uh in the lead by differing
and varying amounts but as a labour
party's national campaign coordinator
i'm not following uh the movements of
individual polls here and there that the
main thing that matters is that we are
um that we are taking our case to the
country that kierstarma has you know
achieved in two years what um neil
kinnick for example took about eight
years to to achieve in terms of turning
the party around making us electorally
competitive again once when we went down
to that defeat in 2019 our worst uh for
nearly a century um you know people were
writing this off for a decade or more
not only has uh kia under his leadership
brought us back into contin contention
got us back on the pitch but we are out
there we are making progress as we did
in the local elections which took place
all over the uk uh just in may this year
we're winning key uh by-elections as
well so we are making very solid
progress under kiers leadership working
from that very low point of our 2019
general election uh defeat so that those
are the real indicators for the progress
that the labour party is making you'll
forgive me if i'm not going to uh you
know comment on every single poll
there's many polls they have different
methodologies they're showing slightly
different things mostly they're showing
that the labour party is in the lead
ahead of the conservative party but for
me what matters is are we making
progress in all of the areas that we
need to be winning in if we are going to
win and get a majority labor government
at the next general election and the
answer based on the local election
results and the by-election results that
we've been getting is yes
yeah and sherman i wouldn't expect you
to comment on all the polls but i would
expect you to have a thought about why
it is seemingly so tight still
considering the disarray that the
conservative party have been i mean they
just
ejected the prime minister and now
they're battling it out to replace him
and the labour party is only a smidgen
ahead
well no partly what you're going to see
reflected in some of the some of the
polls that are taking place at the
moment is a is is a recalibration in a
sort of post boris johnson uh era for
the conservative party but as i said you
know for for me as i plan ahead to the
next general election for the labour
party uh with a you know with a clear
strategy to get to a majority labor
government at that next general election
uh which will be a stunning achievement
based on our 2019 general election
result what i'm focusing on is not
individual polls uh which will fluctuate
and the polls have been extremely
volatile for some time now there are a
lot of voters out there who are up for
grabs as it were who haven't made up
their mind and who are willing to change
their mind and it's our job to take the
case to them for the labour party and
persuade them to trust us with their
vote at the next general election
whenever it comes and as i say we have
made progress uh if you look at our
results in the local elections where we
won in the popular vote across uh the
seats that we would need to win in order
to form a majority labour government we
were winning the popular vote uh in many
of those seats which means that we will
be winning them at a general election uh
if that was taking place now and we made
progress in the wakefield by-election a
seat that we took off the tories only a
few weeks ago which had added as it were
to boris johnson's uh woes and was was a
key driver in removing the prime
minister from his position so the labour
party is making electoral progress in
the ways that it matters which is actual
results that are being delivered on the
ground
i appreciate that shimano no one's
disputing the progress that's been made
it was a really low ebb when the party
was led by jeremy corbyn so to move on
from that is uh something that
definitely should have happened but i
wonder if this is a an issue of
leadership at the moment there is still
a problem isn't there with whether
labour party members people in the
shadow cabinet can go on to picket lines
can you just clear up what the decision
has been made by sakirstama as to
whether people should be on the picket
lines because we saw lisa nandi there a
couple of days ago she was reprimanded
but not sacked sanitary was set to a few
days hence before for being on a picket
line
well there's a there's a clear
difference between both of those uh
instances and so
let me just explain you know because
care has made very clear that we are a
government in waiting we want the people
of our country to put us into government
at that next election and we want that
election as soon as possible and think
it should happen as soon as the new tory
prime minister is elected a government
in waiting has to behave seriously like
a government
and be the you know model the behavior
that we would have in government if
you're a government minister you need to
be able to get around a negotiating
table with public sector unions pay
officials worker bodies representatives
and get to fair negotiations and act in
good faith you can't do that if you walk
off you know if you get to that
negotiating table by pick from picketing
at a picket line so it's been very clear
that you know labor front venture should
not be picketing at a picket line but
there is a world of difference between
that and uh you know members of
parliament meeting workers in their
constituency talking to them about the
issues that are affecting them their pay
their conditions how they're struggling
with the cost of living uh crisis that
is behavior you'd expect not just from
labour mps by the way but you'd expect
it from all members of parliament to
engage with their constituents and talk
to them about the issues that are
affecting them that's what lisa was
doing the reason that um sam terry uh
was uh was removed from his post was
because he broke collective
responsibility when it came to doing a
media round from a picket line and
making up a labour party policy on the
hoof that is not acceptable for labour
front ventures you would expect us all
to maintain discipline and collective
responsibility when that is broken there
will be consequences but there is a
world of difference between that case
and all members of parliament wanting to
engage with their constituents as is
completely right and proper i would
expect tory mps to be engaging with
workers in their constituency if they
profess to care about how the cost of
living crisis is affecting everybody
they should be talking to workers as
well
siobhan and you've made your point very
forcefully thank you very much
national campaign coordinator for the
labour party thanks for your time